A few years ago, I suddenly lost my parents, and now I have four siblings who are
all living together. This is Yuzuki. Itadakimasu
food. There are three guys, so we
eat a lot. My brother has finished his laundry, but I'm
also an older brother. I'm a junior high school student.  I want you to
enjoy yourself and not worry about us, which is just a little bit like a train.If you don't eat outside today, let's go home.If you
wander around, you'll be arrested.If you're
home, there's daifuku.Oh, don't
tell me properly.
We live in harmony like this Yo-
san, maybe I'm offended. It's okay. It's natural for me to
think about it. I wonder
if I can't go out if I sing and play. My brothers and I have always been a family, so the four of us
support each other.  Live
[Music] Let's
go
[Music]
Thank you DET